You'd be checking social media constantly and,
and also if you're,
you know,
your controversial like he is,
a lot of people are talking shit to him and that would hurt his feelings and
saying mean things to them.
And social media has gotten to the point where I'm on it all day and I'm like,
I'm not having any fun.
No,
it's really gotten to the point where,
what is this experience?
Facebook is a nightmare.
It's elderly people screaming at each other.
This was a website where kids were trying to get laid in college.
This is elderly people screaming and complaining.
They can't afford knee operations.
And I'm just going like this all day.
Yeah.
It's,
it's not,
you don't get a lot of bang for your buck.
I've dropped off radically over the last six months.
The last six months I've made a giant,
giant shift away from a reading things and posting things and just,
I like look at it and like for a couple seconds and then I'll put it down.
Um,
or helping our posts.
Yeah,
yeah.
More engaged.
I'm too fucking busy,
you know.
And so what I'm trying to figure out,
ways to better optimize my time.
That was one of the first one.
Stopped reading comments.
Stop reading posts.
Don't just,
just mindlessly shift through Instagram pictures.
Looking for something that strikes me as interesting.
I just stopped doing that and it made a big difference in my productivity.
Yeah,
huge difference.
Yeah.
Cause you know when the,
when iPhone real recently they started putting that thing on your phone.
We see how much screen time you had.
Oh yeah.
It's crazy.
You look at it,
you're like,
what,
five hours and hours,
46 minutes.
Just five hours of nothing.
Yeah.
What did I do?
I get a little out of it.
Right?
Like I'll find new stories I can talk about.
But it's like finding,
I found that like finding the perfect blend seems to be letting the stories get
so big that they get to you anyway.
Right now,
rob.
Dot.
The fringe stories that like the Jesse Small age,
it gets so big you can't ignore about it.
Yeah.
And then you hear,
and I love the day that the day when we all found out it was social media was
great today that we all found out he was full of Shit.
Yeah.
Because then if we could make jokes,
but the three days before that,
everyone was posturing.
Oh,
so start out.
Right.
But then when it came out that it was all bullshit,
everyone's like,
oh,
let's just have fun.
Yeah.
And even though it's,
you know,
I'm not saying that people aren't getting attacked and things aren't bad,
but this particular thing,
if you can't make a joke about this,
what can you make a joke about?
If you can't make a Joseph,
if you,
someone shouldn't joke about this.
Fuck you.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
This is one of those things.
So he,
it's fucking ridiculous.
Insane.
Holding the subway with the fucking news.
My Sandwich.
He pled not guilty in court.
No,
he did.
Yes he did.
No,
Jamie,
he pled not guilty on everything.
Right.
He denied all charges.
Denial.
Oh,
denied all charges.
He's gonna take his own life.
I believe they have the check.
He wrote to them.
He ran check three to five hunch.
He wrote a check already $500 in cash.
He wrote a check.
Now here's the other thing,
I could get punched in five minutes for free.
I could get beat up so easily.
Why is this guy spending $3,500?
Well,
not only that,
why did he write a check?
Do you have no friends?
So he just,
he didn't think this through even a little bit.
Yeah.
God Damn it.
It's disappointing.
It's kind of funny though.
It's,
there's nothing funny right now.
Well,
I think this is what we need.
You know,
we need to understand the outrage machine a little bit better.
Yeah.
And one of the best ways to see it as see manufactured outrage.
Absolutely.
And then you go,
oh,
okay,
this is a hustle.
Well,
the cup and tinting was great because people like wishing death on 15 year old
kids and it's like the video comes out exonerates him and then people are like,
no.
Yeah.
People were doubling down.
People were like,
you can't deny with my eyes.
So I'm like,
are you nuts?
And then I was afraid cause I'm like tweeting things and support the kids.
But I'm like,
what if the next video,
it's just the kids in Klan outfits like this and just dancing around with,
with torches like Charlottesville.
And I'm like,
well then now I look like an idiot.
Yeah,
you can't,
you don't know what to tell him.
You're better off being an observer.
Yeah.
Just let it know people get into the fray.
You just,
you make a little choke.
Sit back.
Yeah.
It's like a gang fight.
You better upstairs standing back and going,
hmm,
I don't want to jump in this every,
every day.
Every hour.
Another fanish pointed that thing was like,
well no,
maybe they are guilty.
Yeah.
You know,
I saw that thing.
It was like a white kid.
I thought they encircled the native American guy who was banging the drum.
And I'm like,
fuck these kids.
Exactly.
That wasn't,
that's not good.
Do you see the first image and you know,
the first image,
which is even crazier,
was put up by a troll account.
Russians.
I don't know who the fuck it was.
Write a know all the problems,
rushing things that came out of Brazil to that,
cause I saw some posts yesterday,
but a few shady social media posts fed a viral firestorm over covering and
Catholic.
Oh,
sure.
Why it will happen again.
Yeah.
These co the,
they're doing this on purpose.
The,
they took that screenshot to try and get people angry and it worked.
And then they Twitter found out that it was a bullshit account.
They've banned the account.
So it's very possible that account was some troll phone.
No,
it's a troll farm.
Wow.
Yeah.
So that's what they'd say,
whipping manipulated.
Now on a level that is like unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
And people were furious.